in the mental health field we prescribe
medications that cause people to gain
massive amounts of weight we prescribe
medications that cause type 2 diabetes
cause heart attacks pause premature
death read the package inserts it's
right there the ketogenic diet helps
people lose weight get rid of their
diabetes or improve their insulin
sensitivity lower their risk for
cardiovascular disease helps them get
off of medications I really don't give a
if their LDL goes up a little I
just don't anybody who is going to get
worked up about their LDL going up a
little bit in the context of all of that
other stuff is an absolute positive
idiot and they are inhumane that they
would let people suffer and writhe in
mental pain and be disabled by their
illness and not offer them an effective
treatment that is just inhumane